tu prenais impôts c'est arrivé très
souvent avec une collègue qui parlait de
ses amours et héros de ses enfants moi
je me disais je lis pas me taire j'ai
une vie c'est suspecte de pas de parler
de ma vie je me souviens très bien de
m'être dit comment faire parce que
c'était pas facile quand même et je
prenais mon courage à deux mains et je
disais moi j'ai pas le même vécu moi je
vis avec une femme où j'ai une amie et
c'était là c'était le comédien
les gens étaient abasourdis ils sont
tous tes pages ne portait pas sur moi
spécialement
gg étonné beaucoup de gens comme ça à
pons et ça me plaisait ça parce que je
disais hé bah oui tu vois hawthorne des
mois c'est pas un garçon
du plus loin que mes souvenirs gambade à
5 ans à 10 ans à 15 ans à 20 ans à 30
ans maintenant beaucoup plus tard je
suis une fille qui aime les filles c'est
comme ça que je me suis tout pas ville
définissez mon identité j'ai pas de
problème d'identité si j'ai une question
à me poser comment une petite fille peut
aimer un petit garçon pour moi c'est
traître je ne connais pas je ne sais pas
de quoi on parle comment est-ce qu'on
peut aimer un petit garçon moi j'aime
beaucoup les garçons je le regrette pas
les connaître mais j'aurais voulu
connaître en gare sont pas en fille je
peux pas connaître un garçon puisque je
suis une fille tu vois ce marche
vraiment sur la tête je pars comment te
dire